there's no need to roll the dice on
understanding the end of Dungeons and
Dragons honor among Thieves here's how
that ending came together no DM required
with the Resurgence of Dungeons and
Dragons it's only fitting that Paramount
set out to bring it to the big screen
once again with Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves the adventure takes
place in the legendary Forgotten Realms
campaign setting of the tabletop game it
focuses on two original characters Edgar
and holga two thieves who embark on an
adventure to write a past wrong the
pair's last Heist ended up putting a
powerful artifact in the hands of a red
wizard named sophina and by the time we
catch up with them they're on a mission
to take it back unfortunately their
former Ally Forge is now working with
sophina and has turned Edgar's daughter
Kira against them now Edgar and holga
must form a new team to retrieve the
artifact and stop Forge and sophina's
nefarious plans like any great Dungeons
and Dragons Quest these unlikely Heroes
face many dangerous and shocking
surprises during their campaign the
film's finale has the most shocking
moments of all though as the group comes
face to face with Forge and sophina to
fight for the people of Neverwinter so
let's delve into the ending of Honor
among Thieves and the biggest moments of
its action-packed climax this is unlike
anything we've ever seen although Forge
and Safina have been working together
for quite some time they aren't quite on
the same page so Fina would rather kill
Forge than continue to work with him and
Forge only has his mind set on
maintaining his wealth and power these
separate motivations see them part ways
in the film's finale Forge plans on
abandoning Neverwinter and stealing the
riches of those he's invited to the
games he plans to sail towards a New
Horizon while sophina turns everyone
into mindless servants so Fina on the
other hand isn't leaving the stadium at
all instead she's going to fulfill her
Destiny as a red wizard to become
all-powerful and rule over the lands
with the help of the magical horn she
enlisted Edgar and his group to steal
years prior Sofina is set to turn the
people of Neverwinter into her Undead
Army by unleashing a powerful Mist that
will kill and reanimate anyone caught in
its path Forge has set her up for
success by bringing everyone into a
packed Arena to be put under her spell
at first it seems like their plan is
going to come together flawlessly but
they don't count on Edgar and his team
spoiling their fun a key part of Edgar's
original plan is having the group's
sorcerer Simon attuned to a magical
helmet that will nullify the spell
protecting forge's fault protect it with
your very life I will
hold this however Simon's lack of
confidence keeps him from being able to
use the helmet properly every time Simon
puts the helmet on he's transported to
another world where he meets his
extremely judgy ancestor he tries to
attune with the helmet multiple times
but gets frustrated and tells edgon that
he can't do it although the group is
forced to go with another plan edgkin
never gives up on Simon in a crucial
moment Edgar tells Simon that he's
better than he gives himself credit for
any time that the group has desperately
needed Simon and his skills he has
always managed to deliver this pep talk
turns out to be exactly what Simon needs
when Simon gets in front of the vault
door he tries to attune with the helmet
one last time with this newfound
confidence Simon fights past his
ancestors doubts and even punches him in
the face to earn his respect and show
his spirit this allows Simon to finally
attune to the helmet open the door and
become even better at Magic edkin might
be the group's self-proclaimed planner
but he isn't exactly the best at his
chosen role if the existing plan fails I
make a new plan so you make plans that
fail no he also plays the loot not
relevant well his determination is
admirable everything around him and his
companions can fall apart quickly as the
group heads into The Big Heist sequence
edkin is constantly changing and
altering the plan to cover up obstacles
and failures his plan a becomes a plan C
and his plan B becomes a plan D
ultimately he ends up combining both
strategies to form one super Heist plan
that somehow Works although not without
some unexpected chaos maybe Edgar
deserves more credit and has a better
grip on the situation than it seems or
maybe he's just winging it and rolling
20s either way Edgar's planning is often
bizarre and frequently puts the mission
in Jeopardy especially in the final
mission
when the time comes for the group to
take their shot at stopping Forge and
Sofina things end up being much more
chaotic than expected the group is
forced to Pivot towards a new plan after
Simon can't attune with the helmet but
this approach shows surprising promise
the group uses the hither and thither
staff to set up a portal in a painting
stashed on a wagon delivering valuable
items to forge as a way to gain access
to the Vault unfortunately the painting
Falls over when the guards put it in the
vault which means the only thing the
group can see is the concrete floor with
that plan suddenly thwarted Edgar
decides to jump back to the original
idea of having Simon attune with the
helmet however Doric realizes that she
might be able to create a hole small
enough for her to transform into a worm
to Slither through Edmund decides that
both plans will run concurrently and
this seeming chaos results in some
shocking success Doric is able to chip a
hole big enough that she can get through
as a worm and is even able to cover up
the portal before the guards can see
even better Simon is able to attune the
helmet and break the magic seal keeping
the vault door protected although both
of edgen's plans work and everyone
except for him makes it into the Vault
they encounter an unexpected problem the
door that Simon opens leads him and
holga to an empty room while Doric is
quickly knocked out after she sees
forges men loading the valuables on an
escape boat while this is all happening
Edgar is giving a tearful apology to
Kira promising to be a better father to
her unfortunately Kira is actually
Sofina in Disguise and Edgar is suddenly
tied up by tentacles as our holga and
Simon desperate to evade death edgon
suggests that Sofina and Forge put him
in his group into the games that Forge
is hosting so that they have a chance to
earn their lives Forge isn't willing to
approve his request but Sofina is she
knows that even if they survive the
games they'll simply become zombies for
the army of Undead when she spreads the
deadly Mist throughout the arena
a wonderful gift for each and every one
of you Edgar might have helped the group
escape a quick death at the hands of
sophina but no one is happy about where
they are now both Doric and Simon are
unable to use their magical abilities as
they are cuffed with a relic that
negates their magic beyond that their
first task in the tournament has death
written all over it the first round of
the games has contestants Traverse a
maze before being slaughtered by a
vicious displacer Beast the maze itself
has plenty of obstacles that could kill
players including walls that fall to
expose their position mimics that trick
Warriors looking for weapons and a
gelatinous cube that digests organisms
that fall into it however the gelatinous
cube actually comes in handy for Doric
as she uses it to remove her magic
restraining cuffs and help the group
escape dork's quick thinking might mean
that edgon has a new rival for being the
group's planner before embarking on the
quest to retrieve the helmet edgin
promises zenk that he will give the
riches stolen by Forge to the poorest
citizens of Neverwinter given that the
group is full of Thieves it initially
feels unlikely that edgen will keep his
promise as it turns out he does in a
fitting bit of payback against Forge the
group sends his valuables tumbling
across the city thanks to the hither and
thither staff while the revenge is
satisfying The Lure of gold also helps
Evacuate the arena allowing the group to
spoil sophina's plan with her plan
thwarted by Edgar's group sophina is
furious and ready to take the party on
herself leading to an epic all-out brawl
in the middle of town dork transforms
into an owl bear for some destructive
combat but is eventually knocked out
holga and edgen hold their own for a bit
but are eventually since spinning
through the town inside a bubble so Fina
traps them in Simon stands the best
chance against sophina but the villain
still comes out on top once Sofina has
them all in her grasp she attempts to
use a time stop spell to make it easier
for her to kill them however when Edgar
starts moving it's revealed that Simon
was able to stop the spell it's a great
moment for Simon that's made better when
an invisible Kira places the magic
negation cuff on sophina to restrain her
powers dork then wastes no time turning
back into an owl bear and hilariously
throws Sofina around like a ragdoll
until she's crushed by some falling
debris with sophina finally dead and
Neverwinter saved it seems like the
group's Journey has ended however their
cheers of Victory are interrupted when
they see that holga has been stabbed by
one of sophina's daggers since the
dagger is imbued with red wizard magic
Simon's Powers won't be able to save
holga she's going to die although she
knows she's doomed polga is proud that
she was slain in battle and fulfilled
the mission of her people by protecting
the helmet while stopping a red wizard
plus she feels like her family is right
by her side and is happy she did enough
to protect them Edgar and you're a help
holga pass on by singing one of Edgar's
old Melodies until the infection caused
by the red Wizard's magic consumes her
it's a tragic end for holga especially
since she's become a mother figure for
the group and Kira when he sees how
devastated Kira is Edgar makes a
difficult Choice after spending the film
desperately wanting to use the tablet of
Reawakening to resurrect his wife he has
a change of heart when he sees how much
hulga means to Kira ultimately he
decides to use the tablet to bring holga
back it's an immensely fulfilling moment
in Edgar's character Arc and a big step
in his journey to become a better father
and a better person sure it's a crushing
blow for Edgar since it ensures that he
will never see his wife again but in his
heart he knows that it's what's best for
his daughter with sophina defeated and
their group reunited the four
adventurers take refuge at the wood elf
enclave and talk about their time
together edgen and holga discuss what
they might do next and Simon takes a
shot at asking dork out again this time
she takes him up on the offer and Simon
seems delighted Forge attempts to escape
through the woods but is stopped by zenk
and taken to prison there we see him
attempt to plead his case for parole
Justice edgon and holga did at the
beginning of the movie however he is far
less Successful by the end of the film
it doesn't seem like Edgar in the group
need to worry about forage anytime soon
and can continue on in peace for now at
least
now for the biggest question of them all
is Dungeons and Dragons honor among
Thieves going to have a sequel at the
moment there has been no word of a
follow-up film and the movie's
mid-credits scene doesn't give any
answers it's mostly just a last laugh to
send moviegoers out on but the sign of a
sequel happening are very good the
reactions and reviews for Dungeons and
Dragons honor among Thieves have been
incredibly positive so far and the movie
has the potential to be a solid hit at
the box office if Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves is a big success
don't be surprised to hear that edgon
and his crew are returning for another
adventure we do know that sophina had a
superior red wizard who could easily
make for an antagonist in a follow-up
movie on the other hand Dungeons and
Dragons has the potential to be a bigger
franchise touching on stories outside of
the one presented in honor among Thieves
with how expansive The Dungeons and
Dragons property is thanks to its
different campaigns and settings this
franchise can easily have plenty of
spin-offs that introduce radically
different characters stories and genres
if this first movie does well enough we
could be seeing a lot more Dungeons and
Dragons content in theaters for years to
come
anything you want to add
I'm good